Ignore the naysayers,
rook you ass off,
and give back and change the world
because if not us,
who,
if not now when?
What is the secret to success?
The long version is that the actually
always had five rules and everything
that it did.
Always use those five rooms,
those five rooms help it to become
successful in various different areas
and I think I believe that those rules
can be applied to almost anyone and
everyone.
You don't need to be a bodybuilding
champion.
You'll either need to want to be a
governor of California or the be an
action hero or anything like that.
If you want to excel in whatever you do,
those rules are for you.
It's that simple.
Now I have to tell you right off the top
that I always was very intense as a kid.
That radio was very intense and I was
very hungry.
I always wanted to be the best.
I always wanted to be.
Number one.
Always wanted to get to the top.
I never believed in.
Just getting by.
Now I have nothing against people that
just want to get by because I think
there are many roads to happiness,
but I think that we all here like to be
successful and we are driven,
so that's why those rules apply to you.
So my first rule is find your vision and
follow it.
You see,
I think is the most important thing that
we have a very clear vision of where we
go a goal,
where do we go?
Because you can have the best ship in
the world,
you can have the best cruise liner,
but if the captain does not know where
to go,
that ship will drift around the world
and outdated.
See and will never end up anywhere.
And this is exactly the way it is in
real life.
If you don't have a goal,
if you don't have a vision,
you just drift around and you're not
going to be happy.
This is why it is so important to have
that vision.
Now,
I created that vision in Austria because
I grew up after the Second World War,
Austria,
right along with Germany.
Lost the Second World War.
Thank God.
Uh,
and the problem was that everyone was so
depressed because they lost the war,
that there was alcoholism everywhere.
There was of course depression,
there was a economic situation,
there was famine,
there was starvation and all of those
things.
And also it was kind of a little place
in narrow.
I felt kind of I wanted to get out of
there.
I wanted to escape and they couldn't see
myself really do work there in the state
of the work,
in the factory of the work on the farm
or the human to follow my father's
footsteps and to become a police
officer.
I couldn't see that either.
Some havoc.
That's what my parents wanted me to do.
They wanted me to become a police
officer and to marry a girl by the name
of Heidi
and to have a bunch of children and do
random round like the funk trapp family
and the sound of music.
But that's not what I saw.
This was the vision of my parents but
not mine.
And Luckily one day in school I watched
the documentary about America and I
found myself.
I knew exactly that is where I wanted to
end up.
I wanted to be in America.
Everything that I saw in that
documentary I just loved every was so
big.
I remember the tall skyscrapers,
the monsters bridges the giant freeway
is filled with beautiful cars.
The huge jetliners movie stars,
Muscle Beach and all of those things.
I could not wait to get there.
The question was just,
how do I get there?
How do I get the America?
I mean,
there's just another common thing to do.
Way Back in the fifties.
No one had the money to travel or
anything,
but one day I was fortunate enough to
see a magazine and that magazine showed
me the path to America and it was a
bodybuilding magazine.
On the cover was is very muscular guy
that was standing there like Hercules,
Hercules outfit.
His name was rich park.
This rich park was on the cover and I
remember the cover said,
Mr. Universe becomes Hercules star.
I read the article as fast as I could,
learning about how he grew up in Leeds
in England,
poor and how it trained five hours a
day,
every single day and trained and trained
and trained and lifted weights,
and then he finally became Mr. Great
Britain,
and then he became Mr. Universe,
if anyone a second Mr. Universe,
title in the third Mr.
Universe,
title,
and then all of a sudden he landed in
Rome in gender chitter doing Hercules
movies and they made millions of dollars
and this,
this money.
He took embodied themselves,
that gymnasium chain in South Africa and
he became a successful gymnasium owner
and as I read I became more and more
certain about my own future.
As I read this story,
I was so excited,
so interested and knew exactly that I
wanted to become another ridge park.
I know he laid out the blueprint for my
life.
Basically I could see myself,
I could visualize myself clearly to be a
champion and that same stage where he
won the Mr Universe and then to move to
America thing,
get into movies and then become rich and
famous.
I had that vision very clearly laid out.
I was so happy that I knew exactly where
I was going from that moment on
everything that I did.
No matter how hard I had to grow or how
much I had to struggle,
it didn't matter.
It was a wonderful choice,
right?
Because I knew what the purpose was and
I found my passion.
The simple truth is,
if you don't have a vision,
if you don't have a goal,
if you don't see a future laid out in
front of you,
you're just floating around without the
purpose,
and I think that the numbers speak for
themselves.
This is why so many people around the
world are unhappy with their jobs.
I mean,
in America,
74 percent of the people hate the job
and would like to change jobs,
but think about that.
That means that only a quarter of the
Americans love the life's work.
I mean,
that is a very depressing statistic.
I always smiled when overlooked the
middle,
how hard I grew up.
I always had a great time.
No matter what I did,
it didn't matter,
but was in bodybuilding over.
It wasn't the movie,
so it was this governor.
I remember in the pumping iron days,
people ask me in the gym all the time,
why are you smiling all the time?
Why are you so happy?
You have to lift 50 tons of weights.
You have to train five hours a day.
I mean,
I look at the other body bullets,
faces and lift the spaces and did look
kind of depressing.
That looks sour.
They're miserable that they have to lift
weights.
You look miserable,
you look happy,
and I tell them always.
I smiled because I know exactly what the
every rep that I do,
every set that I do,
every weight and the lift,
they get one step closer to turning that
vision of mind and the reality of
becoming the Mr Universe.
I couldn't look weight to lift 500
pounds in the squats.
I could not wait to do another thousand
sit ups.
I couldn't wait to do bench press bench
press more girls and I couldn't move my
arms anymore because I knew that every
rep got me close to the standing on that
stage as a champion,
so matter of fact,
then I lifted weights.
I didn't really feel like I was lifting
weights.
I felt like I was lifting a trophy over
my head each time I lifted and they'll
have all those body builders around me
and thousands of people screaming.
Can I tell you that this patient didn't
just help me in body building?
It helped me with everything.
Like I said,
I remember in the movie business,
deb was many times stunts that they had
to do it.
I got hurt.
That was in pain and agony and that to
do it over and over again.
I remember one incident specific young
Conan the barbarian.
There I was crawling on all fours,
on rocks,
over rocks and gravel,
holding my swords right in front of me
and us that was crawling.
The cameras followed me.
It was around 30 seats,
the crawl under rocks and gravel,
and eventually after 10 takes my elbows,
my knees are bleeding and hurting and
the director came to me.
She pushed me and said to me,
he says,
do you mind if we do another take?
I need a closeup of you?
And I said to them,
no,
I don't mind at all.
I said,
go into as many takes as you want.
This says,
no,
no.
I don't want to do that because I know
you're in pain.
You're bleeding.
I said,
no,
no.
I don't feel any pain.
I said,
the only thing I see is,
is the finished scene.
I see the finished scene of me crawling
on all fours with may sort than the
front crawling up and sneaking up behind
salsa doom,
the main building of the and movie that
killed my parents and rising up behind
him and cutting his head off.
That's what I see.
Remember,
crush your enemies.
See them driven before you.
And here the Lemann Foundation of their
women.
So this is why,
because I visualized that scene,
this is why I did not feel that pain.
I did not care if I was bleeding on my
knees because I know that pain is
temporary,
but the film is permanent and I
explained that to the director.
So this is why I tried to tell you,
always discover your vision and the rest
will follow.
Now,
my second,
my second rule is never ever think
small.
If you're going to accomplish anything,
you have to think big.
You have to go and shoot for the stars.
The biggest challenge most people have
is because they think small.
The reason why people think small and
why did you choose small little goals is
because they're afraid to fail.
They know that if you shoot for big
goal,
then the chances of failing of very high
and they're afraid of failing is one of
the most common things.
Why people are frozen by the book make a
moving live because they're scared of
failing.
I said to myself,
Hey,
I'm not worried about failing because
that's part of life.
You're not going to go going when
everything and how far can you fall?
Look at this.
This is the ground that's as far as I
can fall.
Didn't know something that the only time
you really considered the failure is if
you fall and you don't get up,
but if you get up,
you'll never considered a failure.
So I never considered myself a failure.
I always considered myself a window even
though I fell every so often,
but I always got up and I always move
forward.
This is the important thing.
I never had any patients of course,
thinking small because in German we have
a saying,
Ben Shahn,
Dan,
Sean,
that means that if it was something
thing,
go all out and do it.
Well,
this was not just the case in
bodybuilding.
I didn't just want to be a bodybuilding
champion.
I wanted to be the greatest bodybuilder
four times.
I wondered if the muscle,
the muscle of all times,
the most definition.
I wanted the window.
Most trophies,
the most world championship titles.
I just wanted to be the best in the same
as Jose movies.
I didn't just think about being in
movies,
no,
I wanted to be a movie star.
I wanted to have above the title
building.
I wanted to become the highest paid
entertainer.
I basically wanted to be another John
Wayne.
What's wrong with that?
And then the same as in politics.
I didn't just want to go and be in
politics and end the,
uh,
raised for city council.
I'm in,
let's be honest,
the said sound bites.
What's Nega city council?
No,
come on.
What's that guy?
May or no,
it had to be schwartzenegger running for
governor,
but not just any governor,
but governor of the greatest state in
the United States of California.
That was the important thing.
I give you an example of big thinking
big when that became governor wanted to
rebuild cody corneas,
ancient infrastructure.
You see,
America has been living off
infrastructure that was built in the
fifties and sixties and it drives me
absolutely insane that America hasn't
started rebuilding that infrastructure.
I mean,
we invested in new roads or new transit
on schools,
so in energy or anything like that for
decades,
the number of cars that we have,
nine America have four times as many as
we had in the sixties,
so therefore we should be having four
times as many freeways,
four times as many tunnels for them,
many bridges and orders,
but we don't.
So this is why I wanted to get our act
together and do the upgrading least in
California.
So when I talk about infrastructure,
didn't really want to just fix roads and
fixing close some holes in the roads.
I wanted to build massive free on top of
freeways.
I wanted to build the first high speed
rail in the United States.
I wanted to build what bridges and
tunnels were on ramps and off ramps.
I wanted to see literally cranes
everywhere.
Well,
there was no excuse for us to get stuck
in traffic and there was no excuse
really to send your kids in overcrowded
classrooms and schools and there was
also no excuse that Los Angeles has a
100 year old sewage system that's
shitty.
I think
at first,
of course some of the legislators looked
at me like I was absolutely insane.
Mentor told him this vision.
They were willing to spend maybe $5
million dollars,
which of course is petty cash.
He can be to what my vision was,
but so some politicians hip hop to see
the big picture because they didn't
really ever travel outside California.
So they haven't really seen big
infrastructure.
They haven't really seen big
infrastructure all over the United
States or maybe in Asia,
in China or in Korea or in Brazil or in
European countries or here in Australia
maybe.
So they haven't seen that.
And then of course the other politicians
that simply don't have a vision of the
future past the next election,
which is a common one.
Politicians of all over the world.
So it is.
It was my job as governor to motivate
them and to take them into.
To see the traffic jams in Los Angeles
and to see the overcrowded classrooms
and to see all the problems that be
happy to keep pushing and pushing the
pump them up enough that eventually this
salt,
the big picture and eventually Democrats
and Republicans came together.
It'd be invested $60,
million dollars.
You'll be billed California
infrastructure,
the biggest investment of our state in
50 years.
So that's what we did because we had a
big vision and everyone bought in on
this big vision.
So remember,
never think small.
Think big.
My third role is ignore the naysayers.
I think it is natural that we have the
big vision and big dreams and you have
big goals that people are gonna say
around you.
I don't think it can be done.
I think it's impossible or no,
I tell you this all the time,
but I want to tell you,
don't ever let them stop you from
dreaming and from shooting for the Gore
because eliminators simply those words,
no impossible and it can't be done.
I mean,
in each one of my careers when someone
said it's impossible,
I heard it's possible when someone said
it can't be done.
I heard it can be done,
and when someone said no,
then I heard loud and clear.
Yes,
so this is what I believe.
I am a big believer of what Nelson
Mandela said.
He said,
it always seems to be impossible until
someone does it and that's exactly
exactly what it is.
And I wanted to beat that one.
That does it.
I wanted to break the new records and I
wanted to do something that no one else
has ever done.
So I think that's what you need to do.
Don't ever be worried about that.
Someone hasn't done it.
Just think about how many times my
career would have stopped.
My career would have ended if I would
have listened to the naysayers.
I mean,
it started right away when I was 15
years old and I became a bodybuilder
right after it happened.
I said,
I want to be a world champion in
bodybuilding.
I want to be missed or universe.
They immediately said,
are you crazy?
You're in Austria in Australia can
become a ski champion or bicycle
champion or something like that,
but bodybuilding is an American sport.
Forget about it.
It's nuts.
Then men,
they wanted to move to America.
They said again,
it's impossible.
You will never be able to do that.
You have no money.
Your by yourself.
And then when I wanted to go into show
business after I won 13 world
championship titles in bodybuilding,
I said,
I'm want to the park.
I want to be a hercules.
I want to get into movies.
Well,
I tell you,
when I met those agents and managers in
studio executives,
their reaction was
so funny.
You want to be what?
Leading,
man.
Oh,
come on.
I mean,
look,
first of all,
let's start with your body with your
body.
I mean,
you overdeveloped your gigantic.
You're like a monster.
Are you kidding me?
Do you know what the news thing?
The new trend is?
His little guys like Dustin Hoffman,
our Pachino.
Woody Allen does set a new sex symbols.
Sonia,
get it,
and then your accent.
Oh,
it gives me the chills.
Just listening to your German bullshit.
Come on now,
I mean.
Oh God.
I mean it's that good.
Scary when you talk.
It's unbelievable.
I mean,
have you ever.
I mean this year is,
have you ever seen an international
movie?
Stop the German accent.
It doesn't happen.
Forget about that.
And then your name,
what is it?
What's the Schnitzel or something like
that?
Yeah,
I can see that name already up there and
the billboard years and people are going
to storm the theater,
the movie houses because what's starting
to move it?
Oh yeah,
I can see that already.
So that's what they said.
They said to me and says,
look,
forget about that.
You're a nice guy.
I mean your body building champion,
why don't you
or health food store or something like
that.
He can help with that.
And then it.
Yeah,
the side.
Some little pots like maybe playing a
bouncer.
I mean did your body perfect or maybe a
wrestler.
Oh I have a good idea.
But you accent the Nazi officer now.
That's really great for you.
I called my buddies over at Hogan's
heroes.
I mean they would probably use someone
like you.
So that's when they said imagine that
every way I turned.
They said,
no,
it won't happen.
It's not going to happen and forget
about it.
Luckily I did not listen.
I didn't listen because I knew if I
worked hard enough and I've.
I grew up as hard as I did embody
willing five,
six hours a day that I will make it,
that I could prove them wrong.
And I started working very hard.
I started taking acting classes,
English classes,
speech classes,
dialog classes,
even accent removal classes.
I ran around all day saying lines like a
fine wine grows and the binder
goes.
You see the Austrians and Germans have a
difficult time with the B and w and did
the FBI get it on big stuff.
So it was a fine wine grows on a vine or
the sink is made out of zinc and all
those kind of lines is it over and over
and you know something.
All of a sudden I got a little break in
the early seventies.
I remember all of a sudden I got a TV
show,
a little part.
Then another little part and then all of
a sudden I got a phone call from Lucille
ball to be in her special happy
anniversary and goodbye,
which was with Connie.
I had this six minute scene as an
Italian,
Missouri that most people don't get the
difference between an Italian accent in
the German accent,
so I got away with my German accent,
but I played this Italian Mr and I was
so delighted and then right after that I
got that guest starring role in streets
of San Francisco with Michael Douglas
and Karl Malden and then pumping on and
stay hungry.
And then of course I landed the big role
as Conan the barbarian.
So finally I got the big,
big break.
It was so interesting about it was that
soon as we were finished with the Conan
movie,
we were out there on a promotion to a
and the director said that the press
conference,
the directors,
John [inaudible],
he said,
if we wouldn't have had what's Watson
that go with those muscles,
we would have had to build one.
They'll think about that before.
It was this huge obstacle to have this
body and all of a sudden the director
says,
if he wouldn't have had schwartzenegger
going to be this body,
we would have had to build one now.
What a turn around,
and then when I did Terminator James
Cameron said,
which was really great.
He said that I'll be back.
Became one of the most famous movie
lines in history because of Arnold's
crazy accent because he sounded like a
machine.
So as you see everything that the
naysayers said was a liability became an
asset.
Same as also in my political Korea.
When I ran for governor,
they immediately said,
I shouldn't do it.
It is a big mistake.
It won't happen.
I will lose and all those kinds of
things that the rest of course is
history.
The bottom line is,
if I would have this is my career would
have ended up and that was 15 years old.
I will be still yodeling in Austria in
the Alps and that would not be talking
here.
The day the you and the reason why I'm
here today in talking to you is just
because it did not listen to you can't
though.
It's impossible or no,
so I just recommend to you very strongly
ignore the naysayers.
Is Brooke your ass off?
Nobody ever stumbled up on success by
accident except maybe the guy who found
gold in California,
but don't ever think that you can be
that guy.
I'm an idiot.
You never want to fail because you
didn't work hard enough.
I always believed no stone unturned.
Work your butt off.
That's what I always believed.
The middle.
What you do,
Brooke.
Brooke,
I remember Mohammed Ali,
one of my great heroes,
had a great line in the seventies when
he's.
When he was asked how many sit ups you
do?
He said,
I don't know because I started counting.
Only when it starts burning,
it starts burning.
That's when it starts counting.
You see?
That's what makes you a champion.
It doesn't matter what area you're in.
No pain,
no gain.
The bottom line is one of my rules,
which is broke your butt off if you
don't apply that rule,
all the other rules won't mean anything.
I mean,
it drives me absolutely nuts when people
say,
I don't have time to work out who got
that many times I don't know if I'm too
broke out or I have worked so hard all
day.
I'm tired.
I cannot work out anymore.
Oh,
I cannot read another book or I improve
myself or I don't have time or whatever.
Work so hard that I cannot really
improve my business or I can grow as a
person or any of those things.
What the hell of it?
Talking about here,
I mean today is 24 hours.
You sleep six hours,
so you have 18 hours left.
I mean,
I know there's some of you out there
that say,
well,
wait a minute.
I asleep actually eight hours,
but it's asleep fast.
Okay.
You didn't get bogged down with this
stuff here.
Listening to.
I came to the United States.
I remember that I trained five hours a
day every day and it was managing a
construction business and that was a
brick layer and I went to college also
and that took acting classes from 8:00
at night to 12,
midnight of that in one day.
Every day I did that.
I did not worry about it.
I knew that at 24 hours and I didn't
want to waste one single hour because I
believe Ted Turner said,
was one of the great under Brunner's who
started CNN and so on.
He said,
early to bed early to rise.
Grew up like hell and advertise.
So that's what I believe.
Just remember,
you can climb that ladder of success
with your hands in your pockets.
You must work your ass off.
It said simple.
My fifth and last rule is don't just
take,
give something back.
Leave your mark in the world.
I believe that we all have an obligation
to do something for our community,
something for our state and something
for our country.
We must show good cause to this greater
than ourselves because we all know that
in the end we will be judged not by how
much we made,
the how much we give.
Ever since America greeted maybe dope
moms.
I've had this sense of responsibility
and I felt obligated to give something
back to America because I know that
everything that I have accomplished is
because of America.
If it's my body building career,
if it is my show,
Business Korea,
my political career,
the money they've made,
a great family that I have.
All of this is because of America,
but I have to recognize the fact that
America did not become the land of
opportunity in this great country by
itself.
No in history,
people work tirelessly in America.
People fought and died to make it the
land of freedom and opportunity in the
land of liberty.
So now it is our responsibility.
If we want to keep it the number one
country in the world to grow up for that
and to give something back to that
country.
And it doesn't matter if you're in
America,
if you're in Australia or if you're in
China or in Japan or in Italy,
it's the same thing.
You all have to give something back to
your country,
and by the way,
you from the love,
the words of my father in law,
Sargent Shriver,
who started the peace corps,
job corps,
legal aid to the poor during the Kennedy
and during the Johnson Administration.
He was the number one public servant
that he always inspired me to become a
public servant.
He was one of my heroes.
He's said at Yale University of the
commencement speech.
He said to the students here at Miro,
he had down that mirror that makes you
always look at yourself and you will be
able to look beyond that mural and you
will see the millions and millions of
people that need your help.
And I saw those millions and millions of
people,
and this is why I tried to take every
opportunity that I could give something
back.
I started training special Olympians.
People did went intellectually
handicapped to help them with weight
lifting and power lifting.
I became the national power lifting
coach and the torch torchbearer for
Special Olympics,
then laid on a joint,
the Simon Wiesenthal Center to fight
prejudice so we don't have the things
happening again.
Uh,
as we had during the Second World War,
during the Nazi Reich,
ed,
I joined also the president's council on
fitness that became the chairman or the
President Bush from 1990 to 1993 a to be
the German and to promote health and
fitness in all 50 states at Robert.
All 50 states.
I started afterschool programs for the
most vulnerable children for inner city
children to make them be able to say no
to drugs,
no to gangs and violence and to say yes
to education and yes,
the life and every single time I reached
out and I gave something back,
I felt fantastic.
Nothing made me happier.
I would rather play chess with an eight
year old kid in an afterschool program
or play golf around the golf with a
special Olympian and go down another red
carpet of a movie premiere.
And I have nothing against movies or to
give something back to me is more
important than just to think about
myself.
Eventually.
The joy of giving back was so great that
I decided to become a public show
fulltime and determined by back.
I should walk away from my career as an
actor.
After they're finished promoting
terminated three,
I jumped into the race,
into the governor's race in California,
and that ran for governor.
And even though my friends advised me
not to do that,
they said,
are you crazy?
Don't you understand that you would lose
now this 20 to $30,000,000 a movie that
you're getting paid and they will only
pay you $178,000 as governor year?
Well,
I didn't care because I knew that all
the money that I've made and the being
that position in the first place to make
this money is because of America.
It was time to give something back.
So I became governor.
I didn't even take the $178,000.
I give it back to the taxpayers because
it was petty cash.
It's the last thing I needed
and I can tell you that
that those seven years were the most
exciting and the most rewarding and the
most gratifying years of my life to work
all day long to solve problems and to
serve the people was absolutely heaven.
He was the best job I've ever had,
but they also knew that eventually it's
going to come to an ent enough to two
terms.
It did come to an end,
but then he came to an end.
The one thing that didn't come to an
aunt and was not finished was my desire
to be a public servant and just to have
the people,
and this is why I continued to grow for
Special Olympics.
That's why I continued to grow on
fighting my fitness crusade and
traveling around the world to promote
health and fitness and this is why I
continue to support afterschool programs
and be even started the Watson institute
at the University of Southern California
to continue to inspire students and
leaders around the world.
To find solutions to complicated issues
and to give back to make the world a
better place.
So because.
Yeah,
but I tell you
that I was very fortunate that I had
great heroes,
great heroes that they could look up to,
and I mentioned two of them,
Mohammed Ali and Sargent Shriver,
my father in law,
but there's other great heroes like
Gorbachev,
Reagan,
Mandela,
great leaders like Mother Teresa,
chancellor Kohl and Churchill,
and the list goes on and on.
I mean,
this people had such an impact on the
world,
single handedly changed the world.
I mean,
if you think about,
just go up at Jeff.
I mean this man.
Every time I meet him,
I'm in all.
I mean,
he grew up on the communism and he rose
from the bottom of the rank,
straight up to the top.
He can president of the Soviet Union,
one of the most powerful people in the
world,
and he was the lead of the Communist
Party and Benny wasn't a top position.
He realized that the system was broken.
Now what do you do when you at the top
leader of the Communist Party and do
realize that the system,
that communism doesn't work well.
You know,
what did,
did he dismantled communism?
Think about the courage that it takes.
Guts did it takes to do that.
Think about the Gorbachev completely
transformed his country with class,
knows to give his people for the first
time,
freedom and dance through perestroika,
reforming Russia's economy.
He didn't wait for the next president.
He didn't complain.
He simply said,
if not me,
who and if not now,
when,
so I feel very strongly,
all of us need to have an embrace.
That kind of spirit.
We all can create change whether it is
not a neighborhood or in our local
schools or in our country.
He can be big,
but it can also be as little as just
going to a school kit that has problems
reading and teaching kids how to read or
how to do math.
We don't have to just work on me.
We should also work on we,
not just me,
but also remember that lead a truly full
live you must give back.
You must leave the world a better place
than you found it is.
The bottom line is it is up to us.
I mean those rules that I've given you.
Important rules,
but giving back is one of the most
important rules.
I guarantee you that if you follow all
those rules,
you will have many victories to
celebrate.
You will leave,
you know you're broke and you have
extraordinary kind of a record and you
will leave a legacy behind that you can
be proud of.
So I want you to remember those rules.
Have a vision.
Think big.
Ignore the naysayers.
Work your ass off and give back and
change the world because if not us,
who,
if not,
now when.